this muscle is spurting babies
biologists at Cambridge University have
just discovered that females of this
endangered freshwater muscle species
will move to shore attach themselves to
the bank then blast a larva-filled
stream of water a meter through the air
that's 23 times their own body length
the same as you spitting babies about 40
meters or 131 feet The larva in the jet
then parasitically attached to the gills
of passing fish and grow into juveniles
no other species of muscle has been seen
doing this so best of luck with the
survival of your species you baby
squirting little freak Vsauce one story
down five to go this is mind blow
turn your phone into a makeshift
fluorescent microscope we owe much of
what we know about cell and tissue
development in the human body to
fluorescent microscopes it produces
clear beautiful images of tiny cells
that help highlight and identify
specific molecules and Tiny biological
structures while a team of biologists at
Winona State University in Minnesota
have just figured out a way to use
off-the-shelf components to turn any
smartphone into a fluorescence
microscope for only about 30 bucks
called a glow scope it's made up of an
LED flashlight theater filters and a
smartphone this is an amazing tool for
Hands-On Science Education they even
posted full instructions to build your
own online so you can finally study
those zebrafish embryos you've got in
your garage
atoms can play baseball with chilled
rubidium a team at the Korea Advanced
Institute of Science and Technology
through chilled rubidium atoms a
distance of 4.2 micrometers which would
be a full kilometer for a real baseball
they dropped the temperature to zero
degrees Kelvin just above absolute zero
and tossed it into two Optical traps
generated by 800 nanometer lasers the
atom pitcher wouldn't sign with the
Yankees let me tell you that the
rubidium fastball moved at 65
centimeters per second or 1.5 miles per
hour but it's not actually about
replicating baseball testing and
refining this technology can eventually
make quantum computers millions of times
faster than what we have today
now for a very special happy fourth
birthday to rage Shadow Legends the
turn-based battle game with a focus on
collecting Champions I grew up getting
about one video game a year in the 80s
so seeing these graphics on my phone
downloaded for free is insane there are
over 650 unique Champions that you can
customize in billions of ways with new
Champions and updates every month and
incredible boss battles I take a Conan
the Barbarian philosophy when it comes
to playing raid ravage your enemies
assault all bosses impale online
Challengers destroy and hear their
Lamentations and to celebrate raid's
fourth anniversary there are dedicated
offers free gifts promo codes events and
a brand new Fusion event where you can
get your hands on an anniversary themed
legendary champion use my link in the
description or scan my QR code to get
amazing bonuses like epic Champion
Kellen the shrike and super useful items
once you're in game after clicking on
the links just enter promo code four
years raid for four legendary skill
tomes and much more so hit my link in
the description or scan my QR code and
come find find me under the name vsauce2
Kevin and big thanks to raid for
sponsoring vsauce2 feel sober instantly
with a shot someday maybe biochemist at
the University of Texas have discovered
that an injection of fibroblast growth
hormone 21 also known as fgf21 cured
mice of alcohol-induced dizziness and
impairment they recovered from alcohol
six times faster than mice without it
and when scientists gave the shot to
mice who had passed out from alcohol
they woke up twice as fast the hormone
doesn't actually get rid of the alcohol
in the subject's bloodstream it just
stops it from impacting their nervous
system so you're still drunk you just
don't feel drunk researchers say their
Discovery could be useful for treating
loss of consciousness and impaired
mobility among people with acute alcohol
poisoning but no word yet and when
you'll be able to order One Bourbon One
Scotch and one fgf 21. the T-1000
Terminator begins with this snail
engineers at Carnegie Mellon University
in Pittsburgh have created a
breakthrough in soft biotics a flexible
self-healing liquid metal filled Organo
gel with metal-like conductivity that
can support electrical motors and
digital electronics so far they've used
this incredible advance to create this
snail it may move slowly but when
researchers cut the circuits that
powered its Locomotion the Organo gel
healed itself and restored almost 70
percent of the lost power making it the
first of a new generation of robots with
integrated regenerating sensing
movements and probably a desire to
terminate snail John Connor ancient
Romans really wanted this dead guy to
stay dead the tomb of an imperial Roman
Noble family was recently excavated by
archaeologists at Catholic University
leuven and it contained a body sealed
with an unheard of three separate
protections to stop them from coming
back from the dead first the body was
burned inside the tomb and left there
which is extremely rare in Roman burials
second it was nailed down with dead
nails that had been intentionally bent
and disfigured a known ancient charm
against evil magic finally they sealed
him under a layer of quick lime covered
in heavy tiles to stop the body from
rising again no Roman burial has ever
been found with all three of these
ancient Protections in one place so let
me know what you think this guy did to
earn an unprecedented level of zombie
proofing
and now a news report on the Nintendo
Entertainment System from 1988 should
parents buy these games at all the
National Coalition against television
violence thinks they shouldn't because
they say they're bad for kids she
doesn't like this girl's mother doesn't
like the game because she thinks that
you're going to bring them while you're
watching it maybe you will be brain dead
from staring at this thing all the time
no
[Music]